George gasania is one of hundreds of
thousands of motorbike taxi drivers in
Kenya struggling with Rising costs four
months ago campaigning for elections
William Ruto said he'd help them and
other small Traders with government
loans
Pluto was announced the election winner
and sworn in a hundred days ago
the money became available last month
and George took out the maximum loan
he's allowed which is about four dollars
borrowed and repaid using a mobile money
service he says he spent it on fuel that
was not enough for a day but it was
enough for a few hours for that day it
doesn't help but it doesn't help
Ruto was Deputy president for nine years
before he ran for the top job promising
change we are all citizens previous
administration of former president Uhuru
Kenyatta was accused of unsustainable
borrowing from China for infrastructure
projects and marred by numerous
corruption scandals collaboration since
taking office Ruto says he's Reviving
The Economy we have fought
you will continue to engage the
International Community as we Implement
our plan
Reuters had a flurry of meetings with
U.S officials signing trade deals and
securing loans from Western financial
institutions his government said little
about trade with China
activists are concerned that prosecutors
have dropped corruption charges against
ruto's allies for various scandals
totaling more than 250 million dollars a
lot of people are worried that is there
anybody who's going to be held
accountable because some of the largest
cases that were currently pending and
now poof they vanished
subsidies on fuel and some staple foods
have ended since Russo took office that
was a condition for borrowing more money
from the West
Joseph wangi another motorbike taxi
driver says he voted for Ruto but
nothing has improved this government is
a Sim like they have a battery
this there's no difference because the
other
what we are dealing with it's the same
thing
some economists say things will get even
worse before they can get better Kenyans
are waiting to see Malcolm Webb Al
Jazeera Nairobi